congratulations on this film big
congratulations on this film I gotta say
the moment it was finished I was sitting
with our Sony guy in Canada shout out
Grant I I talked to him I was like give
us the next one right now
yeah it's so fantastic thank you so much
congratulations again thank you um I'm
curious about your relationship to the
idea of uh Spider-Man and the whole
spider-verse before you started the
first film and how that's changed now
because even for myself as a big fan I
remember seeing the pitch for the first
movie and being like Okay um curious how
this is gonna go and it turned out to be
so successful I I too had that moment of
wondering what uh what this was going to
be like and how exactly it would turn
out and I think it's safe to say at that
point uh
I don't know that anyone could have
predicted what ended up happening um
with the the reach of into the
spider-verse um
I feel so lucky and so grateful to be a
part of something so special and I think
where
walking into it as a fan of the
character Spider-Man of what we've seen
of Spider-Man in the past uh this has
touched me in ways that I
just have have never felt before I've
never experienced before this has
obviously become such a huge part of my
life we've been working on across the
spider-verse for the last four years so
even before that the four years prior to
that um this is this has become a part
of me uh and the messaging in this film
doing these sessions almost feel like
you're just sort of
doing a few hours of like affirmations
um the the messaging is so special and
so important and so beautiful in so many
ways and for so many people of all ages
from anywhere in the world that uh it
just is like it serves as an incredible
reminder that um you can take that leap
of faith and once you understand and
feel what it feels like to walk in your
purpose great things can happen how
amped were you when you started to see
how much more Gwen gets to do in this
one so excited so excited we we learned
so much more about her we get to dig a
little deeper into her origin story and
spend more time with her she's an
incredible character so I really loved
the fact that it was very clear the
filmmakers weren't weren't about to let
this bold bold voice uh go unheard yeah
now we know there's another one do you
know what happens like did you do this
one and the next one I haven't no I
listen all I know is this thing comes
out on June 2nd and beyond that I I my
emails have been written my calls have
been made I'm waiting to hear back can't
wait to hear back I love that what would
you say is your own real life superpower
not not shooting webs not flying right
um my real life superpower
huh
I think a quality that
a superhero
should have is selflessness
um confidence
and kindness the desire to want to help
people and want to make uh the space
that we're in a better place so those
are all things that I I strive for uh
so I guess in a in a way maybe maybe
those things what about Jimmy but I
think she makes me priorities
wow
well I think he also I think he has all
those qualities
um
I think his his acting is his superpower
I think he's an incredible Talent
um I was lucky enough to be in the in
the room in the booth with him this time
around we didn't get that chance the
first time uh even though
I got his I got his you know performance
in my in my headphones uh it felt like
he was in the room because it is so
strong uh that it absolutely carries but
there is nothing like um being in the
room and having that real-time
interaction and that real-life banter um
and I think that with the evolution of
Glenn and Miles this time around you can
really feel that that there was an
evolution in our process as well that's
an interesting note to make you know
oftentimes I'll be chatting with actors
who have done this and they're just in
the booth by themselves the whole time
and the first time they got a chance to
hang out with their co-star is like that
was that was my experience in the first
one with with just about everyone
um I mean I met them for the first time
uh you know at a photo call yeah um so
it is wild but this time around I did
have the opportunity to work with a few
of the actors so that's um again it
makes the world's difference so was it
interesting seeing their process like
their take on how to bring that
character to life in a voice Booth
absolutely it it's a rather challenging
thing that I may have underestimated at
one point I think there is this sort of
preconceived notion that voice acting
consists of like
not as much uh as a live action because
of the lack of the physicality but
you're in there and you're still I mean
these characters are swinging from
buildings and and jumping off walls and
and you know losing their breath and uh
trying to keep up and you know you can't
you can't portray that standing still so
so it is it is it's a wild uh thing the
uh what it looks like in in a recording
booth for a movie like this do you ever
see that footage back of yourself no oh
my God no and if it exists I would not
like to see
so
the qualities of a superhero
you've got Gwen we've got Kate Bishop as
well like you're firmly entrenched in
like the superhero thing which is really
from uh an observer standpoint a
wonderful place to be what does it feel
like for you to be in that spot oh my
God it's absolutely wonderful to to be
given the opportunity to be trusted to
take on such loved loved characters uh
it's it's an honor and a privilege I I
just feel so grateful to be a part of
this big big world
um and to play a small part in it uh
it's
very special could we see uh some sort
of multiversal movie where you get to
play both roles at the same time wow
here's the thing
anything is possible and if there's one
thing I've learned while being in this
universe uh that is that anything can
happen so uh and at any time so yeah I'm
right there with you waiting to see what
happens
um I loved your turn as Kate and I was
we had an interview over Zoom a while
back
where I was just saying I was so excited
for the future of Kate and maybe some
Young Avengers things I know this might
be the part where you're like I don't
know but I'm just saying you must have
gotten this sort of feedback from a lot
of people from fans saying you know
Kate's a huge part of this team who
would you love to be with you like what
is what does that look like to you would
you imagine that can you imagine
yourself as like the leader of a Young
Avengers team who would you want to be
with you
you know I I think one of the best parts
of this job is
first of all I get to do what I love in
all of it and the fact that that
resonates with people
from around the world is
it blows my mind
um and having played Gwen having played
Kate I have had interactions with people
um who are
also very excited about the future of
Kate and and while I I don't know what's
happening uh I as a fan of the character
as a fan of the story uh I cannot wait
to see what happens and again I can just
tell you I feel so so honored to be
um trusted to play such an amazing
character uh there's always talk about
okay what's the training regimen like
for like an action movie a real life
action movie what's the training regimen
like for doing something like this
because you got to keep that voice fresh
you got your hours and hours on end do
you know I mean you know the work yeah
what's it like prepping for that
a lot of Throat Coat tea uh
sometimes I would if I had to do a lot
of yelling and or Screaming I would do
like a slight vocal warm-up to to at
least feel like I was
using the right placement in my voice so
I didn't walk away feeling
tired vocally and or like I may have
done some damage on the vocal cords
um it's definitely something I've become
more aware of again the first time
around I was just in that booth and
yelling and screaming and and as I would
in in a live action and you don't it's
kind of like you're you're doing it you
don't even know you're doing it because
it's it's just happening yeah um but in
a booth you're you're a lot more aware
of the fact that
what's happening in this film is not
happening right in front of you um I'm
unaware of the the levels and the
soundtrack and the score and how loud
things are going to play and how it will
be mixed and and whatnot so
um just just you know like anything
looking after after myself and
um taking breaks when needed the best
part too is that the the team behind
this thing is an absolute dream and it's
also just been the most
the most collaborative experience I've
had
um there's nothing like I I know I've
said this a few times already but there
is truly nothing like
your directors and other filmmakers
trusting you to do what you do
um it's so freeing to be able to go into
that space and and have the confidence
um in yourself to do what you are there
to do was there a big difference in that
between the first movie and the second
movie like coming into the second one
did you know okay I know how my
collaborators are they trust me more
like were you more ready in that sense
absolutely I think I was most ready in
the sense that
I I knew what I was getting myself into
first time around just every every
session I was like what is going on and
every time I'd be showing a little like
rough sketch or a pre-vis of something
and I just was like I this looks great
guys I you know we'll wait till we see
the theaters and
um this time around I I understood yeah
who I was working with and what was
required of me and um and I also am
playing a character that I know now uh
which there's a lot of confidence that
comes with that